في مدينه العقبه الجنوبيه الاردن اجتماع
امني سياسي شارك فيه كبار المسؤولين
والسياسيين من الجانبين الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني بحضور اردنيا مصري الى جانب
مبعوث الرئيس الامريكي للشرق الاوسط
بريتارك وقال البيان الختامي الاجتماعنا
الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي اكد
التزامهما بجميع الاتفاقات السابقه بينهما
والعمل على التحقيق السلام العادل والدام
كما اكد الجانبان الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي
التزامهما بخفض التصعيد ومنع المزيد من
العنف
كما اتفقت الاطراف المشاركه في اجتماع
العقبه على اللقاء مجددا في مدينه شرم
الشيخ المصريه في شهر مارس اذار المقبل
من جهتها افادت وسائل اعلام الاسرائيليه
نقلا عن مسؤولا اسرائيلي انه تم الاتفاق
في اجتماع العقبه على تشكيل لجنه امنيه
مشتركه تفحص امكانيه تجديد التنسيق الامني
بين السلطه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل وكذلك فحص
جهزيه الجانب الفلسطيني على تحمل مسؤوليه
محاربه ما تصفه سلطات الاحتلال بالارهاب
في مناطق السلطه الفلسطينيه
واتفق ايضا على عقد اجتماع اخر قبل حلول
شهر رمضان برعايه مصريه لتقييم التقدم على
المستوى الامني وتشكيل لجنه اخرى مدنيه
مشتركه لدفع قدما بخطوات اقتصاديه بهدف
بناء الثقه
واكد الوفد الايطالي خلال الاجتماع انه لن
يكون هناك اي تغيير بشان قرار الحكومه
اعطاء الشرعيه على تسع بؤر استيطانيه
عشوائيه وبناء تسعه الاف وخمسمائه
جديده في مستوطنات مختلفه مع الاشاره الى
انه لن يتم خلال الاشهر القريبه المقبله
اتخاذ قرارات جديده بشان الاستيطان
من العقبه ومراسله الجزيره تامر الصمادي
تامر على ماذا يتفقوا
وايضا تنضم الينا من القدس مراسله الجزيره
نجوان
وصل
اما جمال اتفقوا على وقف التصعيد في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه وقف الاجراءات
الاحاديه بين الجانبين الجانب الفلسطيني
والجانب الاسرائيلي هذا وفقا للبيان الذي
صدر عن السلطات الاردنيه خلال الدقائق
الاخيره تحدث عن جمله من النقاط تحدث عن
اختراقات
وتقدم ايجابي وصف بالايجابي وفقا للبيان
الاردني وهذا التقدم الايجابي اشارت اليه
الجهات المجتمعه والحديث هنا عن الولايات
المتحده الاردن مصر بالاضافه الى فلسطين
والجانب الاسرائيلي
واكدت هذه
الاجتماعات التي استمرت لساعات طويله في
الحقيقه التي بدات منذ ساعات الصباح
واستمرت حتى قبل ساعتين من الان كانت
اجتماعات مغلقه مغلفه
بستار سميك من السريه بعيدا عن اعين
الاعلام في منتجعات هنا في العقبه
الساحليه لم يسمح لنا بالوصول الى ذلك
المكان السلطات الاردنيه بررت هذا الاجراء
هذه الخطوه بالعمل على الوصول الى توافقات
مرضيه الى حد ما وفقا للجانب الفلسطيني
والاردني تفضي الى اشهر من تخفيف وتيره
التصعيد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه لا سيما مع
اقتراب شهر رمضان
الفضيل والاعياد اليهوديه تحدثت او تحدث
البيان الاردني في الحقيقه عن اتفاق
الجانبين على وقف التصعيد والاجراءات
الاحاديه من ثلاثه الى سته اشهر في خلال
الفتره المقبله تحدثت ايضا عن وقف مناقشه
اسرائيل لاي بؤر استيطانيه جديده اقامه اي
بؤر استيطانيه جديده
لمده اربعه اشهر او سته اشهر وتحدثت ايضا
وقف اقرار اي مستوطنات ايضا لاربعه اشهر
وتحدثت ايضا
السلطات الاردنيه عن يعني عوده التنسيق
الكامل والاتفاقيات السابقه بين الجانب
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي لكن هذا الاجتماع
قبل برفض شعبي لا سيما من المعارضه
الاسلاميه والقوميه واليساريه لكن السلطات
الاردنيه نهايه جمال رات في هذا الاجتماع
مصلحه فلسطينيه واردنيه في ان واحد